[Music]
good morning Dawn's Wednesday December
5th two other people are doing projects
similar to song Wednesday charlie is so
cool is doing it in the vlog lovers
Channel and a B to R is doing it in her
new songs from a hat series I am very
excited about both of these under the
song you see I've got these problems and
no one can solve them I'm embarrassed
just to say it out loud
either I'm loving you where should love
her love anew the West should love you
it's just who I am I'm not proud
it's just who I am I'm not proud
but baby you look so good I wanna spray
you on my could I would eat you like a
five-year-old eats glue it used to be
that my favorite things in the world or
food
they still are but now my favorite food
is you
[Music]
we all love Chinese lo mein and snow
peas says wah all new shoes
but I used to want to procreate with
endplate that I ate and that's the
difference between me and you
yeah that's the difference between you
not good and read xx even with bad tax
max I once kissed a grilled kangaroo
imagine John Belushi making our sushi oh
that was me before I met you
yeah that was me before I met you
[Music]
but baby you look so good I wanna put
you in my barbecue if I could I would
eat you like five-year-old it's Louie
used to be the my favorite things in the
world
we're food well they still love now my
favorite food is you
well I must conclude that when you need
and recently shampoo that my mood is
more suited for you than food
potatoes and carrots they need to be
stewed but I want to stew you - yeah I
want to scare you too
Oh baby you look so good I wanna put you
in my stare if I could I would eat you
like a five-year-old eats glue it used
to be that my favorite things in the
world or food well they still are but
now my favorite food is you
baby I promise not doing you but I can't
stop wanting to and I'll try to stop
making out with food
[Music]
you've helped me lose a lot of weight
and that's pretty great it's just one
more reason I love you
[Music]
that's just one more
I love you
but still you will be so good I wanna
spring so you are my food in if I could
I would eat you like the five year old a
flu is to be the my favorite things nor
we're food well they still love but now
my favorite food is you
Don I fixed the newsletter anyone can
now sign up and people who haven't
received the confirmation email will
soon be tomorrow